la personne partira dès ce soir
elle part elle par là je vous le dis et
pas ce soit partira demain matin donc ce
soir elle dort à l'hôtel
elle part demain par le premier avion
quelle part à miami direccte directions
les jurés vie c'est là une vie ça c'est
parfois jean-michel douati rejoint les
jean-louis à 58% non
le oui a gagné jean-michel du parti
merci jean michel
ils partirent en donnant son nom à
toutes les femmes avaient entendu de
jean-michel merci à la production de
l'accueillir merci voilà mes chéris jean
michel vous êtes contents non mais dans
l'absolu je suis content parce que c'est
du boulot génial non mais non mais je
vous jure que c'est vrai vous partez
demain ça sera pas du nom mais ça ne
veut pas qu'on allait faire ça sur fond
vert non non vraiment je vous le jure
vous serez ami jean michaud il se trouve
que j'ai une fille depuis seize ans déjà
mais je vous l'avons ce soir eh bien
elle peut faire avec vous l'école elle
passe le bac qui m'ont aidé
[Applaudissements]